i believe in america
america has made my fortune
and i raised my daughter in the american
fashion
i gave her freedom but i talked her
neighbor to this honorary family
she found a boyfriend not an italian
she went to the movies with him she
stayed out late
i didn't protest two months ago
he took her for a drive with another
boyfriend
they made her drink whiskey and then
they tried to take advantage of her
she resisted she kept her honor
so they beat her like an animal
when i went to the hospital her nose was
broken her jaw was shorted
held together my wire
she couldn't even whip because of the
pain
but i went why did i whip
she wasn't like with my life
beautiful girl
now she will never be beautiful again
sorry
i i went to the police like a good
american
these two boys were brought to trial
the judge sentenced them into trees in
prison and suspend descendants
suspended the sentence they went free
that very day
i stood in the courtroom like a fool and
those two bastards
they smiled at me
then i said to my wife for justice
we must go to don corleone
but did you go to the police why didn't
you come to me first
what do you want me tell me anything
but do what i beg you to do
what was that
that i cannot do
i'll give you anything you ask
they've known each other many years but
this is the first time you ever came to
me for counsel
for help i can't remember the last time
that
you invited me to your house for a cup
of coffee
even though my wife is godmother to your
only child
but let's be frank yeah you never wanted
my friendship
and uh you were afraid to be in my bed
i didn't want to get into trouble
i understand you found paradise in
america
had a good trade made a good living
please protected you and there were
courts of law
and you didn't need a friend like me
but uh now you come to me and you say
i'm currently on and give me justice
but you don't last with respect
you don't offer friendship you don't
even think to call me godfather
instead you come into my house on the
day my daughter's to be married and you
ask me for the murder money i ask you
for
justice that is not justice your
daughter is still alive
looking to suffer then she suffers
how much shall i pay
what have i ever done to make you treat
me so disrespectfully
if you'd come to me in friendship then
the scum that ruined your daughter would
be suffering this very day
and if by chance an honest man like
yourself should make enemies then he
would become my enemies
and then they will fear you
be my friend
godfather
good
someday another day may never come i'll
call upon you to do a service for me
but uh until that day
except this justice is a gift on my
daughter's wedding day
yes that's right
[Music]
uh give this to uh clemenza
i'm unreliable people people that aren't
going to be carried away
i mean we're not murderers in spite of
what this
undertaker's